[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 11 juin bienvenue dans le
journal de tv soixante dix huit pour
faire le tour de l'actualité locale
voici les titres c'est la journée
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers vainement
pour leur rendre hommage une cérémonie
était organisée ce matin à versailles et
les pompiers des yvelines qui ont repris
il ya peu leur grève illimitée ils
demandent une revalorisation de leur
prime de feu et des recrutements
interview et depuis la semaine dernière
la bergerie nationale de rambouillet a
rouvert tout a été aménagé pour
accueillir le public dans le respect des
conditions sanitaires et mais le site
attend toujours son public
reportage à suivre et puis cet artiste
est lent courtois multicasquettes vient
de sortir le géant son premier single
carla la forêt a su faire de sa grande
taille un atout son portrait à la fin de
ce journal
l'épidémie de coronavirus continue sa
lente décrue dans les yvelines où aucun
décès supplémentaire n'a été enregistrée
en 24 heures et depuis le début de la
crise 507 personnes sont mortes à
l'hôpital aux derniers chiffres qui
datent d'hier mercredi les
hospitalisations sont en recul 483
patients étaient hospitalisés l28 placé
en réanimation soit 2 tient en moins
entre mardi et mercredi dans le
département en 2008 personnes ont été
guéries de lakovic 19 après un passage à
l'hôpital
je vous le disais dans les titres c'est
aujourd'hui la journée nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers l'occasion de leur
rendre hommage dans ce contexte
particulier une cérémonie s'est
d'ailleurs déroulée ce matin à
versailles en présence du commandant
stéphane milot nouveau directeur du
service départemental d'incendié et de
secours des yvelines et d'alexandre joly
le président du sdiss 78è les pompiers
du département qui ont pour rappel perdu
l'un des leurs pendant la crise
olivier lugan pompier volontaire des cd
du coronavirus pompiers une profession
en première ligne durant ces dernières
semaines cinq mille interventions peu
vite 19 ont été effectués dans les
yvelines après une légère accalmie les
soldats du feu en ont profité pour
reprendre un autre combat une grève
limité entamé il ya un an l'entretien
est menée par mélanie poker pierre musée
du bonbon jour il ya tout juste un an
toutes les organisations syndicales se
rassembler pour se mettre en grève
pourquoi vous reprenez cette grève
aujourd'hui bonjour effectivement il ya
un an nous étions sur votre plateau pour
déclarer un mouvement de grève national
ce mouvement grève nationale nous
l'avions arrêté pendant l'épisode de
pandémie afin de faire face à nos
missions à 100% parce que ça peut la
culture du sapeur pompier aujourd'hui
malgré l'ensemble des décrets qui sont
signés et des propositions gouvernance
gouvernementale pardon il n'y a pas
d'avancée sur le sujet donc de nouveau
nous allons battre le pavé parisien et
l'est pas il est pavé des villes de
province afin de rappeler simplement à
l'état de tenir ses engagements
si vous demandiez du dialogue social le
maintien de deux commissions drôme
revalorisation salariale sur la prime de
feu est-ce que vous avez obtenu
certaines satisfactions
donc aujourd'hui nous avons obtenu des
paroles donc il ya bien sûr de
mouvements un mouvement national sur le
vecteur de la prime de feu qui est
depuis des années bloquée et nate de
1980 90 et donc on avait demandé une
évolution nous avions tenu par par la
rue l'évolution de cette prime de 19% à
25 %
donc aujourd'hui elle n'est toujours pas
mise en avant
ça c'est le côté national et ensuite
côté départemental nous avions profité
de cette action pour rappeler le monde
de problème d'effectif de sapeurs
pompiers professionnels qui est sur
toute la france et non pas que en
ile-de-france sur toute la france
là on sort encore on y encore un tout
petit peu d'une situation inédite est ce
qu'avec tout ce qui s'est passé vos
rêves vos revendications ont évolué mais
ce sont les mêmes alors ils n'ont pas
évolué elles sont les mêmes et le dirai
même qu'elles sont elles ont martelé le
fait du manque d'effectif puisque à un
moment sur le notre département nous
avons dû augmenter les effectifs de
garde journalier afin de pérenniser
notre réponse à 110 que la charge
opérationnelle était telle qu'on
risquait de ne pas pouvoir répondre à la
mission incendie qui est d'ailleurs la
seule que nous savons et nous avons le
droit de faire
alors justement vous avez aussi été
fortement
mobilisés comme en ont vécu les pompiers
des yvelines toute cette situation
sanitaire il
il faut rappeler que le disent les
yvelines a fait face a fait face l'a
fait face parce que malheureusement
l'état sans créer de polémique mais en
étant très factuelle de pompiers de
terrain était complètement absent sur le
terrain notre maison mère la direction
générale de la sécurité civile est
également complètement absente
donc c'est la synergie de l'ensemble des
départements d'ile-de-france et là
l'expérience de la dta crise des
sapeurs-pompiers d'ile-de-france qui ont
permis de répondre et de faire face tant
en matériel qu'en technique humaine
qu'en ressources humaines c'est vraiment
une inter corporation d'ile-de-france
qui a permis de faire face mais
malheureusement par l'absence de l'état
est notre maison mère la direction de la
sécurité civile
quelles ont été vos principales missions
transporter des malades allaient faire
les premiers les premières constatations
peut être dans malade alors il ya eu
deux missions la première mission de nos
missions régaliennes nous avons maintenu
notre charges opérationnelles sur
l'incendié le secours routier le secours
à victimes et là dessus est venu
s'additionner toute la détresse et le
risque sanitaire
donc deux missions une première mission
qui était d'aller chercher les victimes
identifiées covi et ensuite nous avions
mis en place des véhicules de
reconnaissance afin d'aller identifier
clairement si la victime était dite kobe
ou pas ça c'est la mission
opérationnelle et ensuite le this a
également participé à des missions de
soutien logistique ont matériel en
intervention avec l' agence régionale de
santé
différents partenaires encore une fois
le sapeur-pompier a montré qu'il avait
une action opérationnel mais était
également en action sur une diverses
actions de secours et de soutien à la
population il ça démontre encore une
fois je permets d'insister sur ce manque
d'effectif cruel de sapeur-pompier
professionnel qu'il faut enfin martelé
c'est une histoire de sécurité c'est ma
sécurité en tant que sapeur pompier
c'est aussi votre sécurité
parce que en tant que citoyen vous avez
droit d'être en sécurité et un moment et
on risque d'avoir se fit très tendue et
c'était l'asticot risque de casser et
cette sécurité
certains d'entre vous en ont payé le
prix olivier lude aux infirmier
volontaire alors faire des singeries
il faut il faut rappeler d'ailleurs j'en
profite de cette instance pour d'avoir
un devoir de mémoire à tous de tous les
gens qui ont eu des gens décédés dans
cette crise sanitaire
tous nos frères d'armes sapeurs pompiers
qu'ils soient civils et militaires aux
volontaires touchés par le virus est
également assez à ses partenaires c'est
ces gens qui faisait partie des rangs
les sapeurs pompiers volontaires qui ont
été contaminés à l'extérieur de notre
établissement et qu'ils ont subi
malheureusement c'est triste c'est
triste fin mai une pensée pour lui sa
famille et voilà sachez qu'on leur porte
toujours le soutien
est-ce que c'est aussi une preuve que
vous étiez en première ligne et que vous
avez été touchés un argument aussi
peut-être pour cette prime de risque que
vous pouvez prendre des foyers qui est
l'un d'eux cheval de bataille
alors cette prime de risque oui allez
cette prime de risque on le souhaiterait
à 28 % aujourd'hui elle est annoncée à
25%
oui elle démontre simplement que nous
avons un métier dangereux mais je
profite encore une fois de cette
instance pour vous rappeler que le
métier de sapeur pompier n'est pas
classée dans les métiers dangereux
nous sommes pas un métier dangereux
malgré le nombre de morts que nous avons
tous les ans malgré les risques que nous
prenons donc oui cette s'écrit fanny
terre a également révélé de nouveau que
les sapeurs-pompiers comme beaucoup de
cordes et à d'ailleurs que ce soit la
police les différentes polices les
différentes fonctions la santé dont nous
faisons face malgré l'ensemble des
politiques qui ont diminué tout la
ressource de sécurité et de santé du
citoyen français
vous parlez donc d'actions qui vont
venir vous allez battre le pavé des
dates sont déjà déterminés nous allons
sûrement rejoindre le mouvement du 16
juin avec la santé ils ont énormément
souffert
cette idée de donner une prime et une
médaille c'est un peu lamentable
permettez moi de prendre deux termes je
sors un peu de mon devoir de réserve
n'est sur un champ de bataille
oui on va remercier d'une médaille mais
ce temps là est révolu aujourd'hui nous
avons des gens qui sont sur le terrain
les infirmières qui ont vraiment vrai au
plus profond d'elle-même et ils ont été
chercher très loin la ressource mentale
et physique pour tenir
cette médaille cette prime je prendrai
un parallèle à une époque à rome on
faisait des jeux pour calmer le peuple
aujourd'hui on donne des primes et des
médailles la société a changé c'est plus
du tout le même acteur les mêmes actions
qu'il faut avoir
merci pierre louise dupont vous êtes le
président du syndicat autonome des îles
et le second tour des élections
municipales c'est le 28 juin prochain à
mantes-la-ville seule commune et rennes
ile de france deux listes se feront face
après les retraits d'amity sa médaille
et de romain carbone le maire sortant
rassemblement national cyril note en
tête après le premier tour fait face à
samy damerdji candidat centriste avec sa
liste l'union pour mantes la ville ce
dernier a appelé d'ailleurs dans un
communiqué son adversaire à débattre
face à lui ça me damerdji propose à
cyril note est dit micro débat dans
différents endroits de la ville au
contact des habitants
il accuse les lui je cite c'est d'avoir
refusé depuis six ans de travailler avec
tous les partenaires de la ville et
d'ici le second tour présentation dans
nos éditions des différents candidats
engagés pour le scrutin aux
clayes-sous-bois anne-claire frémont est
à la tête des clayes-sous-bois c'est
vous la liste s'est classé à troisième
après le premier tour
elle ne lui avons donné deux minutes
pour vous convaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une liste qui dépasse les clivages
gauche-droite liste libre de toute
pression politique
une liste citoyenne qui représente
toutes les générations tous les milieux
sociaux tous les quartiers de notre
ville
c'est une liste qui a pour seule
ambition mais l'intérêt général de notre
ville et de tous ses habitants
et c'est surtout une liste où l'intérêt
l'ambition personnelle n'a pas sa place
[Applaudissements]
la pandémie que nous traversons
aujourd'hui nous a montré l'importance
de prendre soin les uns des autres et de
vivre ensemble et justement ça montre
tous les sens d'un haut point phare de
notre programme qui est la citoyenneté
et le vivre ensemble la citoyenneté
ce sera par exemple la démocratie
participative réapprendre à vivre les
uns avec les autres et non pas les uns à
côté des autres
ce sera aussi la mise en place d'un
conseil inter générationnelle
ce seront des des moments festifs des
moments de convivialité et nous ne
serons favorable à toute proposition
d'habitants de claix siens que les
siennes allant dans ce sens du vivre
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
j'en aurai 2 pourquoi deux parce que
encore une fois l'enseignement de la
crise sanitaire que nous traversons a
confirmé l'importance de la mise en
place d'un plan communal de sauvegarde
plan communal de sauvegarde qui permet
justement dhr et des réponses très
établies réfléchi à de futures crises
mais également je pense que c'est elle
souhaite beaucoup de clés siens la
révision du plu afin d'y intégrer la
sauvegarde de notre patrimoine naturel
et bâti qui sont l'identité de notre
ville à rambouillet comme pour les
clayes sous bois
les électeurs auront le choix entre
trois candidats pour le second tour et
david jutier et la tête de liste de
rambouillet en commun il est arrivé
deuxième au scrutin après le premier
tour présentation en deux minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier point fort c'est la diversité
et l'expérience des des personnes qui la
composent
au premier tour on à rassembler le plus
largement possible donc on a des
personnes écologistes évidemment moi je
suis issu de du mouvement du mouvement
écologiste europe ecologie les verts
donc on a évidemment des d écologie sur
la liste on a des personnes qui viennent
du mouvement de benoît hamon génération
points si on a des personnes du
mouvement delphine batho génération
écologie et puis on a également le
parquet animalistes qui nous a rejoint
donc un des points forts de notre lycée
d'avoir su dès le premier tour
rassembler assez assez largement le
point phare je pense que c'est celui qui
colle le mieux à l'actualité
c'est le centre municipal de santé qu'on
réclame depuis des années un centre
municipal de santé
c'est une structure qui piloté par la
ville qui est financé par là par la
ville avec des médecins qui sont
salariés et dont les salaires sont
remboursés par le paiement des
traitements et des soins par la sécurité
par la sécurité sociale et ça c'est une
structure à type de structure une à peu
près 2000 en france qui est extrêmement
attractive et qui est une réponse à la
désertification médicale qui s'installe
sur le sur le sud yvelines et qui est
aussi une réponse au besoin
d'anticipation
[Applaudissements]
on lance le plan pour mettre en place un
système de santé digne de ce nom sur le
sud yvelines à l'échelle du territoire
parce qu'on parle de rambouillet mais en
réalité c'est toute l'agglomération qui
est qu'elle conservait donc première
première décision c'est de mettre en
place tout ce qui est nécessaire pour
construire ce centre centre municipal de
santé est la séance est au programme ce
jeudi soir les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines se réunissent en conseil
communautaire à partir de 19 heures une
assemblée particulière puisqu'elle se
tiendra en visioconférence en raison des
conditions sanitaires à l'ordre du jour
notamment le vote d'approbation du fonds
résilience d'île de france pour aider
les tpe et pme touchées par la crise
cinq cent mille euros seront ainsi
débloqué à saint quentin en yvelines
une séance retransmise en direct sur le
site internet de l'agglomération c'est
un dispositif proposé par les yvelines
est valable désormais aussi dans le
département des hauts-de-seine le pass
malin revient cette année cette carte
permet de bénéficier d'au moins 15 % de
réduction sur les billets d'entrée dans
une soixantaine de monuments des deux
territoires
le passé à télécharger sur internet et à
présenter à l'entrée des sites concernés
dans le département le zoo de thoiry le
château de dampierre ou encore celui de
breteuil à choisel font partie de ce
dispositif
autres lieux partenaires du pass malin
la bergerie nationale qui a rouvert ses
portes la semaine dernière à rambouillet
après avoir assuré une continuité des
soins pendant le confinement auprès des
animaux la bergerie attend désormais le
retour de ces visiteurs tout a été
aménagé pour accueillir le public matic
de demi pour le reportage sur un rythme
de vacances scolaires la bergerie
nationale a rouvert ses portes tous les
après midi de 14 heures à 18 heures plus
d'activité dans les lieux clos
les visiteurs sont essentiellement à
l'extérieur la réouverture donc été
conditionnés à la mise en place
effectivement d'un protocole de
réouverture
nous avons dû mettre en place les gestes
barrières sur l'exploitation mettre à
disposition des visiteurs des masques du
gel hydroalcoolique et instituer un
circuit sur l'exploitation de manière à
ce que les gens ne se croisent pas
devant le corps de ferme une terrasse a
été aménagé pour accueillir les
consommateurs du mérinos café malgré
l'aménagement d'un circuit à sens unique
pour les visiteurs
le retour est encore timide les gens
viennent vraiment par petits groupes et
on sent que c'est moins moins fréquenté
que qu'à l'habitude mais voilà ça
reprend ça reprend tranquillement ce qui
nous permet aussi de nous de reprendre
nos marques de nous réorganiser et on
espère que l'été à venir et les vacances
vont nous apporter une fréquentation
relativement normale en attendant le
retour d'une fréquentation normale la
bergerie nationale va accueillir le pari
fermier qui devait avoir lieu au mois de
mai pour respecter les gestes barrière
l'événement se déroulera sous forme de
drive
les gens peuvent aller sur le site du
pari fermier passé commande auprès des
producteurs qu'ils connaissent et avec
qui ils ont l'habitude de commercer et
donc réserver leurs produits et vendredi
ils pourront venir avec leur véhicule
faire ici le tour de l'exploitation
agricole est passé avec leur voiture de
stands en stands pour retirer leurs
commandes
les visiteurs pourront récupérer leur
commande auprès des 59 agriculteurs
présents de 9 heures à 18 heures le
vendredi 12 juin
le lui retrouvera son public la semaine
prochaine le musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines or ouvrira le 17
juin annonce de l'agglomération
aujourd'hui accès sécurisé et mesures
sanitaires mises en place avec toujours
au programme
l exposition le siège se révolte qui met
en avant une collection de sièges et
canapés design
elle est d'ailleurs prolongée jusqu'au 9
janvier 2021 pour ce site il faudra
encore patienter jusqu'à la fin du mois
réouverture le 26 juin pour france
miniature à elancourt plus de quatre
semaines ont été nécessaires pour
remettre en état le parquet après le
confinement et réorganiser les lieux en
adéquation avec les mesures
gouvernementales à l'ensemble du
parcours avec les 117 monument est
accessible côté attractions seul le
cirque des zinzins l'expérience fort
boyard le chantier des fouilles et t'es
pas cap reste fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
tout comme le restaurant les provinces
france miniature conseille l'achat de
ces billets en ligne pour un accès est
garanti il a fait de sa grande taille
son atout l'artiste élan courtois card
la forêt vient tout juste de sortir son
premier single
le géant un artiste multicasquettes que
l'on a également pu apercevoir sur petit
et grand écran son portrait signé par
aurélie oms
[Musique]
une chanson pour évoquer sa différence
de taille car la forêt est un artiste
élan courteau au profil atypique
puisqu'il mesure deux mètres 06 tout de
suite j'ai vite compris que le basket
c'était pour moi malgré la taille
en fait j'ai fait du basket petit quand
j'étais grand à 12 ans et est en fait
j'étais pas très bon ça me passionnait
pas spécialement et sur les planches
après avoir pris des cours de théâtre
car la forêt investi le petit écran dans
la série vdm et le grand écran avec le
film brise 3 en 2016
aux côtés de jean dujardin il joue le
rôle de carl le jeu on n'a qu'à ça laver
elle s'appelle la classe
alors on m'interpelle tout le temps à y
fait beau la mesure combien machin gmail
en a pas marre et je suis bon en fait ça
permet de 1 go d'ouvrir la conversation
avec les gens c'est quand même super
également musicien autodidacte il
choisit de parler de son quotidien dans
son premier titre le géant qui mêle
humour et musique rock
le clip a été tourné en partie à
elancourt a été finalisé pendant le
confinement
[Musique]
je tournais qu'un petit téléphone un
stabilisateur ap quelques copains qui
m'ont dépanner pour tenir la tarte en
deux temps à autre mais voilà donc je me
suis baladé un peu les yvelines un peu
partout avec mon trépied mon téléphone
en attendant de retrouver la scène quand
la situation sanitaire le permettra karl
la forêt donne rendez vous à ses fans
tous les jeudis à 18 heures sur les
réseaux sociaux pour une web série au
titre évocateur le manteau personnalisés
il est sacrément assaisonner et je vais
donner tout ce fric pour qu'ils aient
plus de service public
alors les impôts mon pull et puis en
cette journée nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers cette intervention pour
le moins difficile mais réussi cette
semaine dans les yvelines le qui a été
sauvé par les pompiers du côté de breuil
boisrobert ce jack russel est resté
coincé 24 heures sous terre après avoir
poursuivi un renard dans son terrier l
unité de risque animalier a été dépêché
sur place et alors que tout espoir
semblait perdu l'opération a réussi le
qui n'avaient en plus rien perdu de sa
vitalité après un séjour dans le terrier
et bravo en tout cas aux pompiers pour
cette intervention est difficile voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi elle demain vendredi ne
manquez pas le 7-8 l'hebdo pour un
condensé d'actualité de la semaine
yvelinoise belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]